hey 42 here of all the planets that I've
lived on I have to say that Earth is
probably my favorite and despite our
best efforts to ruin it it still has
some pretty spectacular features like
the jungles of the Amazon the incredible
mountain ranges that litter the Earth's
crust the Great Lakes of North America
and that Chinese takeaway on West Street
you know the one with the free prawn
crackers the fingers us humans are a
picky Bunch and we're never quite happy
with the way that things up there are
phones to upgrade windows to replace
houses to extend unsuspicious pills to
buy from your junk email folder but what
about the planet itself can we fix any
of those little issues that's have been
bugging us for years like how the Sahara
is a bit too hot
Australia is definitely too far away
from anywhere else and can I just have a
bit of Greenland as I really don't think
anyone else is using it
so grab a paintbrush and let's see if
it's possible to change the planet to
suit our needs can we edit the earth
back in the day the land was all one big
look a supercontinent called Pangea but
the shifting plates have really made a
massive thing since then which is why
you can't cycle for Melbourne to London
anymore remember the good old days one
thing we would like is for the ocean
currents to once again flow mostly
uninterrupted around the equator which
we believe could act to stabilize the
global climate which if you haven't
heard about it's doing about as well as
global politics right now currently the
Americas are sort of in the way when it
comes to having connected oceans so
we're going to have to cut through it
the idea is to supersize the Panama
Canal to the point where it's a lot more
canal and less Panama basically removing
the entire country much to the annoyance
of panamanians and hat lovers across the
world it would have to be done by a
series of underground nuclear explosions
or we could just use a huge pile of
Samsung galaxys the original canal took
about 40 years to build and 25,000 lives
displacing enough earth to build a Great
Wall of China from New York to
francisco and no one in their right mind
would want to build a wall all the way
across america the u.s. actually spent
close to a billion dollars in the 50s
and 60s on projects ploughshare looking
at the feasibility of using nuclear
weapons as a part of a large-scale
engineering projects such as accessing
oil building artificial harbors and
getting rid of entire countries to link
oceans together
apparently there's a fair bit of
negotiating to be done to make this
happen and there's no scientific
consensus on what the outcome will be
with some arguing that nuking the
Isthmus of Panama would actually hasten
the loss of the Greenland ice sheet
instead of slowing it down which is
probably not ideal northern Africa could
do with some freshwater and the nearest
river is the Congo unfortunately getting
access to it involved working in a
region that is still recovering from a
civil war I killed four million people
so unless you're planning on tiptoeing
game with a water bottle probably best
to look somewhere else
and if freshwater is what you want why
not take it from the most abundant
source on earth the Amazon Heinrich
Hammer suggested building a 4,300
kilometre pipe that would pick up
freshwater from the Amazon river's mouth
and deposited all the way over in North
Africa physicists have proposed a pipe
that will be submerged 100 metres under
the surface anchored to the seafloor it
would be 30 metres wide and have 20
pumping stations to keep the flow going
providing North Africa with fresh water
as well as a number of piranhas of
course water doesn't just come from the
ground it also comes from the sky
roughly every 18 minutes here in England
on a good summer's day but what if you
want a bit more of it well you could try
praying too low no Hawaiian god of rain
but since he's also in charge of peace
music and sweet potatoes I doubt you'll
get an answer anytime soon Dubai are
taking matters into their own hands with
a plan to build a mountain the purpose
is to force air to rise thereby creating
more clouds and more
main it sounds great in theory they
already have a number of successful
cloud seeding projects on the go well
they are hoping to find a more effective
solution before all the groundwater is
used up with washing Lamborghinis with
horrific lis ostentatious paint jobs the
whiff in height of the mountain are
still being decided and then they can
work out how much it will cost but it
looks like it will be about half a
trillion dollars or in other words the
average monthly salary in Dubai Dubai is
already pretty experienced that giving
itself plus ik surgery since it's been
creating man-made islands for over 15
years the world's second largest
man-made island is yes and it's due to
be completed in 2018 it will be used to
create many schools in hospital I'm
joking this is Dubai it's covered in
hotels at a Ferrari World theme park the
various island project started because
the city didn't have enough Beach and
they knew that they had to grow the
tourism trade for when the oil
eventually runs out which it will the
first major project was Palm Island
which was designed to fit a long length
of beach in a very compact space first
of all they needed to dredge almost 10
million cubic meters of sand from a
nearby Bay and then they use this along
with millions of tons of quarried rock
in a range of sizes including huge six
ton blocks to create the new land they
couldn't have done it without the help
of the world's greatest land reclaimer
z-- the Dutch who consulted on the
project Lev polder near Amsterdam is the
largest man-made island in the world 970
kilometers squared of land stolen right
back out of the sea what doc geochemist
called Roloffs Keeling had maybe the
grandest idea of all once again in the
middle east at the strait of hormuz
where the gulf sea connects with the
indian
the water is just 39 kilometers across
schooling's idea was to dump the whole
thing once the oil trade dies out of
course because right now there is quite
a lot of tankers using it and it done
would make them very late for work once
the dam was in place the water on one
side would become lower than the other
thanks to the process of evaporation you
could then use this difference to
generate an enormous amount of hydro
electric power about 2,500 megawatts in
this case which would power almost two
million homes unfortunately without the
water exchanging with the Indian Ocean
the Gulf will get saltier and saltier so
you'd probably kill all the sea life so
dolphins you've got about 20 years to
start producing the electricity for the
planet or you've got it coming maybe
start farming electric eels or just give
us back all the oil that BP has so
generously been donating to you over the
years you don't even drive you selfish
source of mammals thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2 kowloon
walled city was home to over 33,000
people all come into a measly six acres
but there's a mud equally as despicable
as adult Hitler yet very few people even
know of his existence